Al ver este diagrama sabemos que la longitud del
segmento AB es igual a la longitud del segmento
AC, por lo que AB -que es la longitud de todo este
lado- es igual a la longitud de todo este otro
lado; y también sabemos que el ángulo ABF es igual
al ángulo ACE, puedes ver que miden lo mismo,
lo que quiere decir que sus medidas son iguales
o que son congruentes, así que este ángulo de
aquí es congruente con el ángulo de acá, miden
lo mismo. Ahora, lo primero que quiero intentar
probar es si BF tiene la misma longitud que
CE, así que intentemos responder a esto. Ya
conocemos algunas cosas que podemos expresar
mejor en dos columnas. Permíteme hacerlo así,
sólo para que veas cómo se hace en caso de que te
pidan demostrar esto en clase y lo puedas hacer
de manera más formal. En esta columna tenemos
el enunciado y en esta otra columna tenemos
la justificación. Voy a reescribir esto de manera
formal en estas dos columnas: tenemos que AB = AC,
este es el primer enunciado y es algo que nos dan,
el segundo enunciado es que el ∠ ABF = ∠ ACE y
nuevamente esto está dado. Ahora, algo interesante
es que tenemos un ángulo y un lado en cada uno
de estos triángulos, y podemos ver que los dos
triángulos -y me refiero a los triángulos ADF y
ACE- ambos triángulos comparten el mismo vértice
A, el punto A forma parte de ambos triángulos,
por lo que podemos decir que el ∠ BAF = ∠ CAE.
Esto deja más claro que tenemos dos triángulos
diferentes aquí, pero en realidad es el mismo
ángulo, este ángulo es igual a sí mismo. Éste es
nuestro tercer enunciado y podríamos decir que es
obvio. Algunas personas llamarían a esto propiedad
reflexiva, es obvio que un ángulo es igual a
sí mismo, incluso si lo etiquetamos de manera
diferente este ángulo va a medir lo mismo, así que
tenemos algo interesante: tenemos un ángulo, un
lado y un ángulo, un ángulo, un lado y un ángulo,
por lo que por ángulo, lado, ángulo tenemos
que el triángulo BAF -este es nuestro cuarto
enunciado- el ∆BAF, que estoy resaltando en azul,
y algo importante en estos problemas es ubicar el
triángulo correcto, así que comenzamos con este
ángulo, luego pasamos al ángulo anaranjado
a través de este lado E que sabemos que es
congruente con ese lado de allí, y luego pasamos
al lado donde el ángulo no está etiquetado, es
el triángulo BAF. Entonces sabemos que el ∆BAF ≅
con el triángulo que comienza en el ángulo blanco,
luego va al ángulo anaranjado y luego va al
ángulo sin etiquetar, va a ser congruente con
el ∆CAE. Este dibujo está medio desordenado, pero
puedes darte una idea de que es congruente con el
∆CAE: el ángulo blanco, el ángulo anaranjado y
el ángulo no etiquetado forman este triángulo,
y la justificación es ángulo, lado, ángulo,
ALA, este es el lado intermedio y estos son
los dos ángulos y eso viene en los enunciados 1,
2 y 3. Y como estos triángulos son congruentes,
sabemos que los lados correspondientes van a ser
congruentes, y este será nuestro quinto enunciado,
el quinto enunciado es que BF = CE, y
esto viene directamente del enunciado 4,
o podríamos decir que los lados correspondientes
son congruentes. Ahora vayamos a otro nivel,
veamos si podemos demostrar que ED = DF,
así que sigamos desarrollando esto y veamos
si podemos probar que ED = DF. Pongo un signo de
interrogación allí porque aún no lo he demostrado,
quiero demostrar que este pequeño segmento
de recta ED = DF, así que veamos si podemos
demostrar esto aquí mismo. Algo interesante y que
no es tan obvio es cómo averiguamos si hay algún
tipo de congruencia aquí, pero ya tenemos algo
de información. Sabemos que BAF ≅ CAE, y también
sabemos que este lado de aquí, el segmento AE que
es parte de CAE, va a ser igual al segmento AF,
estos dos lados son congruentes y la razón es
porque son lados correspondientes de triángulos
congruentes: AF es el lado opuesto al ángulo
blanco del triángulo BAF y AE es el lado opuesto
al ángulo blanco del triángulo CAE, que sabemos
que son congruentes. Entonces sabemos que AE = AF,
y una vez más esto proviene del enunciado
4, e incluso podríamos decir que los lados
correspondientes son congruentes, la misma razón
que vimos aquí. Ahora, lo que es interesante aquí
es que aunque esto de aquí ni siquiera es un
triángulo, pero por lo que sabemos estos dos
segmentos son congruentes, y esto nos ayuda
con esta parte de aquí, porque sabemos que el
segmento AB es igual al segmento AC, eso nos fue
dado. El enunciado 7 es que sabemos que BE = CF.
¿Y cómo sabemos que BE = CF? Bueno, sabemos que la
longitud de BE es igual a la longitud de AB - AE,
que, con base en lo que vimos acá, es igual a AC
- AF, porque AB = AC. Y ya demostramos que AE es
lo mismo que AC - AF, y AC - AF es lo mismo que
CF, esto lo sabemos por el enunciado 1 y por el
enunciado 6. Entonces sabemos que este lado es
igual a ese lado, que esta pequeña parte es igual
a esta parte, y si restas la parte grande menos la
parte pequeña esto de aquí va a ser igual a esto
de aquí. Esto es todo lo que estamos demostrando:
este lado amarillo es igual a este lado amarillo
justo aquí. Ahora, la otra cosa que sabemos, y
esto viene de los ángulos verticales, es que el
ángulo EDB va a ser congruente con el ángulo FDC.
Voy a escribirlo como el enunciado 8: sabemos que
el ∠ EDB va a ser igual al ∠ FDC, y esto viene de
que los ángulos verticales son congruentes o sus
medidas son iguales. Y ahora, de repente, tenemos
algo interesante de nuevo: tenemos el ángulo
anaranjado, el ángulo blanco y el lado, en esta
otra parte tenemos el ángulo anaranjado, el ángulo
blanco y el lado, por lo que estos dos triángulos
más pequeños son congruentes. Ahora el enunciado 9
es que sabemos que el ΔBED, que estoy remarcando
aquí, es congruente con el triángulo... Recuerda
que queremos usar el ángulo blanco, el lado
amarillo y el ángulo anaranjado, entonces B es
el ángulo blanco, E es el ángulo sin etiquetar
y D es el ángulo anaranjado: comenzamos con C,
luego sigue el ángulo sin etiquetar y después el
ángulo anaranjado que forman el triángulo CFD,
y esto viene directamente de ángulo, ángulo, lado,
de la congruencia del ángulo anaranjado, el ángulo
blanco y el lado. Y ahora que demostramos que este
triángulo es igual a este triángulo, sabemos que
sus lados correspondientes son iguales, ya
estamos por terminar. Ahora que sabemos que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes, sabemos
que ED = DF porque son lados correspondientes,
vamos a escribirlo: ED = DF, y una vez más la
razón aquí es igual que aquí arriba, conocemos el
enunciado 9, lo que significa que son congruentes
y los lados correspondientes son congruentes. Con
esto terminamos. Este fue un problema bastante
complicado, pero hay que resolverlo paso a paso,
sólo intenta obtener la mayor información de cada
triángulo y finalmente lo obtienes. Pero la parte
difícil no es darte cuenta de qué enunciado usar
o cómo aplicarlos, sino ubicar el triángulo y
encontrar la información que tiene; darte cuenta
de que puedes encontrar BE al restar AE de AB,
y ver que hay dos triángulos superpuestos en
esta estrella sin brazos o como quieras llamarlo.